liebe leute ich muss mich vielmals
entschuldigen bei commander krieger
mache ich es gleich im video seine mails
sind im fußball mehr untergegangen ich
verspreche ich werde mich bessern und
außerdem fragen lotto wenn man auf die
fresse kriegt dann muss man es auch
zeigen in welchem zusammenhang er diese
philosophie vertritt das jetzt infrage
motto natürlich noch viel mehr
so was haben wir hier genau das fragen
lotto wurde auch schon mal gesehen ja
die grünen sind nahmen uns die roten
gemeinden greift ein
also ich muss leider so machen ich muss
alle fragen beantworten und proteste
meinen damit fand man regen ok
was hast du falsch gemacht im leben das
du dein geld mit dem zocken von
ballerspielen verdienen muss also
dann geht es mal so wenn du an meinen
namen stelle wäre es in meiner position
so würde es nichts anders machen
ja stimmt genau also sorry wer meiner
position ist er macht es einfach zu
gehen
ist das manchmal finde ich wie so ein
geschenk
was dass das so passiert ist
eigentlich etwas was passiert ist
es ist nicht etwas was man plan war das
heißt ein geschenk ich habe auch gern im
casino gearbeitet in der gewissen art
und weise vermisse ich die arbeit auch
ein casino bin ich jetzt so zurückdenke
die arbeit auf der aida war wirklich
scheiße bezahlt nicht verdienen jetzt
mit youtube ungefähr nach handys an die
verdiene aber ungefähr fünf- bis
sechsmal so viel wie ich auch der inder
verdienen kabel und
da habe ich 70 stunden die woche
gearbeitet keinen freien tag gehabt
sechs monate lang das allerdings keine
auf der insel ist kein urlaubsziel und
du hast ein richtig geiles team das ist
das teile das war schweiger so wie
kommst du auf die ganzen winzigen
community aktionen auf deinen channels
wie finden wir ganz ehrlich gesagt so zu
also ich bin kein typ der sich gar keine
gedanken machen der sache mache es
wieder das was ich gestern gemacht habe
ich fahren im auto und irgendwie zack
kommen in eine neue idee wie zum
beispiel mit dem pokerturnier das kommt
einfach so schlimm ist es da und dann
muss man versuchen das ganze ein
bisschen aus zugreifen einfach zu machen
aber noch zeit ja ja wir haben uns einen
ganz entspannten jetzt wir sind
wunderbar zwei das darfst du jetzt habe
ich hier bin ein wirklich wir sind
wunderbar derzeit du sagen selbst dass
du kein besonders guter ego shooter
spieler bist warum müssen wir uns dann
noch videos von deinen sales anschauen
ganz einfach mal einen schwarzen
bildschirm langweilig wäre und wenn ich
jetzt doch irgendwie nur super geile
gameplays bringen würde dann wären
wieder sinn dass unser halters weg nicht
versuche euch zu unterhalten
und wenn man mal hoch auf die fresse
fällt dann muss das natürlich auch
gezeigt werden authentische okay
alles was ich mache jetzt also schon mal
auf ob jemand kennt alle schon mal auf
aber ich ließ noch nicht
aber er ließ baum nicht
minute
dann sitzt hier mal da dran und das geht
dann an die frau
was hat ein düsseldorfer was ein kölner
nicht hat einen platz in der ersten
bundesliga zum beispiel es ist möglich
dass das ein trend bringt der geschicht
werden ich finde gut was ist das
geheimnis deiner wahnsinnsstimme also
ein geheimnis für die stimme habe ich
nicht im gegenteil also wie es einfach
so wie sie ist und ich finde meine
stimme auch teilweise gar nicht so
wahnsinnig schon fängt an ja aber für
mich jetzt nicht irgendwie also ich kann
halt gut lahm und ich habe immer gerne
gelabert ein bisschen stoß vor zellen
muss halt sind
und die letzte gemeine
diese frage kann man eine von dir so
dass wir mal selber was über sich dass
die tage habe ich ganz meinen kollegen
überlassen
die supermärkte was ist mach dich
eigentlich schon dummer spruch also so
wie die leute ihnen feiern kann er gar
nicht dumm sein und darum geht es dass
man einfach was neues was läuft gerade
julians blog hat es jetzt vorgemacht mit
kiko shit überall hört man kikuchi
koschitz schild unser fan kurve gab es
vorher so gar nicht und darum geht's
einfach nur dass man neue sachen
entwickelt kreativität einbringen und
wahrhaftig bezahlen auch drum machen
das ist schon wahnsinn was den einfluss
youtube inzwischen auch auf die ist
wirklich krass zumal ich war bei
rocketeer auf der bühne und es kann man
sofort wenn mir einer mittelfinger
gezeigt hat so ich habe gesagt du kommst
jetzt mal hoch wie auf die bühne
foto gemacht du kommst du arschloch
deshalb ist das arschloch des tages gab
es auf facebook gepostet und natürlich
dann irgendeiner das ist er ja heißt so
und so das ist ein facebook seinen
youtube account alles der typ und
richtig fertiggemacht bei den leuten an
diesem ohr nicht verstehen
also man muss wirklich auch dann
vorsichtig sein dass man nach
also hier noch mal für dich und ich sag
jetzt auch noch mal sorry an dich dafür
dass sich seine mannschaft es war keine
böse absicht
es war kompletten überlastung aber ich
werde mich bemühen die zukunft dass das
nicht wieder passiert also danke dass du
mir was sich sodann commander krieger
und noch mehr fragen lotto gibt es
natürlich bei pixum unter anderem mit
poker der über seinen peter pan komplex
spricht um warum der im bereich gaming
so wichtig ist oder wenn ihr etwa meldet
sehen wollt die auf die provokative
frage antworten ob sie nicht nur eines
muss kopie sind dann solltet ihr auf
dieses video klicken und ansonsten ja
bis dahin bleibt dran